hi welcome everyone and thanks for
making it here on a busy day on campus
it's my pleasure to introduce arica
lumen today Arica got her PhD from Max
Planck Institute of metrology in 1996
she then went and got her post doc or
dealer postdoc at university of victoria
in canada and then got a faculty
position at why I called Dalhousie
University in Halifax stayed there for
seven years and then in 2004 moved back
to Europe to Switzerland and got a
professorship at ETH in Zurich and
that's where I visited arica the first
time in 2006 as a graduate student doing
a research stay abroad and since then Oh
week has been a wonderful mentor for me
and she was my advisory for for my
postdoc and so it's my great pleasure to
have her here today and with that
welcome Rican take it away thanks a lot
for the invitation so it's my pleasure
being here after I've promised or try to
try to come quite a few times but then I
don't fly so much anymore luckily I
don't write so much anymore because now
I'm in a beautiful country as you can
see here so there's no reason to go
anywhere where you can't go by public
transport so yeah so what I'm going to
present today is some of the research
that we have been doing and I do quite a
diverse range of things i look at ice
nucleation in detail and I do climate
modeling so it's a huge spin and
differences and I'm going to present
aspects of both of it and this picture
he is actually taken from a high
mountain peak we have it's called the
young foyer where we are at 3,500 meters
and there's a research laboratory and
it's nice to study cloud processes in
detail because it's around thirty to
forty percent of the time it's inside
clouds and if not you can just enjoy
with scenery there so yeah so I'm
starting with a big view on things I
have also been involved in the in the
last assessment report of the IPCC and
also in the one prior to that and I
guess you're all familiar with what the
IPCC is all about that we are trying to
estimate the different influences that
humans exert on climate and if you do
that we know pretty well by now if you
compare the radiative forcing between
1750 and 2011 that the biggest
contribution is from co2 and other while
mixed greenhouse gases so there's no
surprise there and those of you working
with truda at least I also know that
there's aerosol particles that do the
opposite they have a negative radiative
forcing and what you see here is that
there is a large uncertainty by
associated with that the confidence
level especially when it comes to errors
were cloud interactions is only low we
don't know a whole lot about it but what
you also those of you who have seen the
similar figure from the AR for from the
fourth assessment report that was
published six years ago the numbers were
a little different they are given here
in green so then you can see what what
basically has changed in those six years
there hasn't been a lot of change if it
comes to else or radiation interaction
instead that we call it differently and
I go into that on the next slide but
what you see that there has been quite a
change from what we thought what we know
about the radiative forcing you to arrow
cloud interactions previously 22 now and
I'll also go into that what happened
then and that's worthwhile to point out
if you look at the total anthropogenic
forcing then you see that head that has
increased by quite a bit by point 8
watts per meter square because for one
over that period of time over the past
six years to see you too forcing
increases co2 is constantly rising and
if the total errors are forcing is less
negative that also is the positive for
thing and then what you see is that it
goes up from point 6 I think to 2.2 or
2.3 so it's not a point A to point 60
point 7 that the difference that you see
there so that's as with even more
certainty that we have known before
human changed since industrial times
have contributed to a positive form
forcing IE warming okay so I said that
we have changed the terminology and it's
not to have something new every few
years but it has because the aerosol
community got into the habit and having
its own slangs in saying direct effect
semi-direct louder bedo lifetime
thermodynamic glaciation I don't know
what a myriad of different processes and
if you don't work in that area you
really don't know what that all is and
how important are those differences and
so we decided to classify that a little
more intuitively everything that has to
do with the aerosol interacting with a
radiation is now called a radiant
changes from allison radiation
interaction it's longer but it's more
precise and everything where the forcing
is changed because the aerosol interacts
with the clouds is now called that and
then we have two sides one is the
traditional direct effect is what we
call now radiative forcing and then um
and so this is basically you you have
the error source what they can do is
either reflect or absorb solar radiation
period and that's a pure radiative
forcing you can keep everything else
constant just look at that but in the
atmosphere the minute you you add some
air assaults in there some some other
things will happen for instance if it's
an absorbing arrow so then you warm the
atmosphere the stability may change or
if it's inside a cloud droplet you may
get evaporation going on and so what it
is
is that adjustments occur and they can
be manning for it and so basically what
we have done now is to say everything
that is not the forcing the forcing
meaning you keep everything as constant
constant metrology everything constant
but the forcing agent that you change is
called adjustments and they occur
normally on time sched that are much
faster than the warming that you have
from greenhouse gases so much faster
than what you have over the 100-year
time scale or so and so you can lump
that together and then we call it an
effective radiative forcing and the same
you can do over here here traditionally
this has a zillion of different names
cloud I'll be door to me effect whatever
ads and then you have all the different
adjustments and I go a little more into
that but to start off with into a
motivating that are introducing this a
little more there is actually the
question always is can we observe those
things are this pure constructs or what
what what is this and the cloud I be the
effect is actually something that you
can observe and if you see that you can
see it in terms of ship tricks so this
prominent example here is off the coast
of Washington where you have in gray
some background clouds and over line are
those white tracks and if you look
closely what happens if you flies
through them you can associate what this
is due to because so here this is from a
different study but it's similar an idea
here you have a background cloud
extending over a kilometer and then here
between those two dashed lines you have
the ship track and if you look the
aerosol concentration was ten times
higher within the track going from a
hundred to a thousand per cubic
centimeter and so you see that this is
this is it this is really the
perturbation from the ship you could
speculate if there's like water vapor or
of the heat matters but because over we
are over the ocean
any additional water vapor input would
just be in neglect jable and so then if
you look at the cloud droplet
concentration you see that this
increased from around 20 to 30 in the
background cloud to around 100 within
the track so it's not the same it's not
the same because if you have so many
more and numerous part because you don't
activate them all but you still see it
clear signal here if we assume that the
water vapor hasn't changed then you have
more droplets competing for the
available water vapor so they don't grow
as large and you see that in the reduced
size of the drops and putting this
together more numerous and smaller drops
you see this increase in in reflectivity
in the cloud I biro and so then this is
here what shows up and this would be the
end of the story if there would be so
easy it turns out as it turns out you
don't observe ship tracks all the time
because the environment is not stable
like that all the time it's similar to
cron traits from the airplanes you don't
see them all the time either because
sometimes there are adjustments and the
adjustments that can go on can be larger
than the initial forcing itself and that
is actually another reason to consider
this everything together here because
what good does it do if you have an
artificial forcing and the adjustments
say because you have more numerous and
smaller cloud drops say if they
evaporate much more readily and you
don't see it now this is telling me me
me you that it should be like that but
we actually did do a study a while ago
before the IPCC report came out to
compare this if you can actually compare
the radiative forcing with the effect of
forcing and how different is that and in
order to make the point that what we
really want to be looking at that we
really want to be looking at an
effective forcing where the fast
adjustments are taking into account we
did this for
co2 and methane so for real normal
species and the difference is if you do
it if you do a climate model simulation
where you do a radiative forcing
calculation what you would do is as I
say you keep everything constant but you
vary the forcing agent so either the
greenhouse gas concentration the aerosol
concentration or cloud rob number and
everything else is constant whereas what
you do here is the method that normal
GCMs do it that way you just have two
different simulations starting with
different emissions one was pre
industrial ones with present day and you
look at the difference but then what you
get automatically are all those fast
feedbacks they are all included there so
what we and the other thing is you
cannot disentangle them anymore once
they are included because you only see
the final product so you don't know what
each individual effect is and so we did
that here to prove that you can actually
do that we did this for co2 here in
black methane that there was still
called the direct aerosol effect and the
indirect aerosol effect and you see so
this is different climate models in
these different categories and the
important point to note is they pretty
much lie on the one to one line except
for co2 and that has to do with its
cooling in the stratosphere so if you
look at the forcing at the tropopause
instead of the top of the atmosphere you
get into agreement and then you can
decompose it but basically the message
here is global mean values are
comparable we also looked at this that
it you Denali so this is owner means
here from the different models and it's
a similar answer here so this is in
black is the pure forcing calculation
and in rat it's with the fast feedbacks
and this is for the eclair oviedo is
first indirect effect or what we now
call radiative forcing you to errors
will out in the actual and for all the
models
basically if you take fast feedbacks
into account you get a just a noisy
version but you get more or less the
same answer so you said okay if this is
so then actually ipcc can change and now
really include the effect of radiative
forcing and this is what we have done
and this is probably the summary slide
if you work on hours or cloud
interactions where all the knowledge
that we have gathered is included in
actually stems from an early version
that water puts together and where she
basically started to be really good to
every paper that was published that on
errors of cloud and direction she
reported what the forcing values are and
that's what we took over for IPCC and
what you see here is like this would be
the direct effect and this year would be
the pure forcing so first indirect
effect and this here is no actually not
pure it's the effect of radiative
forcing due to errors or cloud
interactions so the indirect effect with
fast-food bags included and he is the
sum of direct and indirect and we said
really what we are interested in is the
sum of that because this is what matters
right it's the combined forcing that
offsets part of the greenhouse gas
warming so this is what we interested in
and then the problem is if you look at
this the different symbols present
different studies so this year is prior
to that the fourth IPCC report was
published this years after that this
group here of models is interesting and
I come back to that later on and those
are the ones that are used for forward
calculation for future simulations and
those models have to agree with the
observed temperature record so there are
models in here that if they included
hours of cloud and direct
James would have not been able to
reproduce the observed temperature range
but it would have caused them to cool
because of that they don't have it but
you can see that overall they have
rather smaller science than if if you
compare this to the overall box and then
there's some other studies that are both
highlighting this year's tool it's paper
for instance those are the ones that
consider also errors all affected mixed
phase clouds and that's quite a spread
that you can see here what we have been
doing because the IPCC is that you have
to come up with an expert judgement of
what you think is the right value we
said okay to do that we only consider
the latest version of any given climate
model because there's only three climate
models or so they really look at Arizona
effects or mixed phase clouds as what
truly does what I do and some others not
too many a little more it's for actually
all together because we have four stars
but in order not to bias it towards our
models we only consider the latest
version of each modeling center and then
there were some models that take aerosol
effects and convective clouds into
account and you see here even a much
larger spread and you see something that
can't be possibly true because the minus
3.5 watts per meter square negative
forcing would have set there's no
temperature warming we actually go
towards a cooling and the other thing to
notice is that here is some studies
where satellite data were taking into
account and they overall have a much
smaller radiative forcing and this is
partly because I was just reading with
some with with somebody before the
satellite of course has the problem you
cannot detect errors and cloud at the
same time and you cannot look at warm
clothes low-level clouds of the earth's
clouds overlying so they are biased
somehow but we don't know to what extent
but if you take the average of the
satellite studies it comes out to be way
less negative then if you take the
average from the GCMs and we were
stuck with starting asking us what is
the truth what is it really what we know
then all we know is that probably the
truth is somewhere in between and that's
why we picked the value that's somewhere
in between but we inflated the
uncertainty range because if you only
focus on the newest studies you have
quite a narrow range and we know that
the uncertainty is much much much louder
than that so the expert judgement and
this is then really people sitting
together and discussing it until you
have heard all the other arguments
somewhere that the Oversoul total
aerosol forcing should be negative minus
point 9 with an uncertainty range
between point one and minus nine watts
per meter square somewhere there but
they are still uncertainties from that
and I'm actually now switching topics a
little bit and go a little more into why
ice why mixed face clouds why ice is so
uncertain and it's actually one of one
of the reasons why ice is so uncertain
is because ice crystal formation can be
done in very many different ways use
what you see here is the relative
humidity with respect to ice and he is
the temperature and if you form a cloud
a normal of water cloud you find cloud
droplets that are formed very close to a
hundred percent relative humidity but
that is not true if you go to ice clouds
they're super saturations with respect
to ice they can be up to 170 180 percent
quite high and you don't form a cloud
and that's very very different and that
is because we don't have so many aerosol
particles acting as ice nuclei around
and so that is one point I come back to
that but also the question is how how
are the arrows was interacting how are
they acting as ice nuclei they can do it
by collision colliding with a super cool
cloud droplet so that has to be here so
this black line is at water saturation
this
happens once you have already water
droplet that collides and freezes or you
could have the ice nucleus being
immersed in the droplet initiating the
freezing or you could temporarily build
a water film that freezes all the drops
and that will happen in deep convective
clouds for instance if you if they rise
quick enough and there's no suitable
eyes nucleus in it then they could
freeze homogeneous Lee once the
temperature somewhere below minus 35
minus 38 degrees centigrade or when you
look at cirrus clouds then if you have
it typical to eject or relating to a
cirrus cloud it normally the air parcel
normally Rises through cloud free air
and then what could happen to there's
two possible ways or three actually one
you could have a solution droplet like
surf sulfate aerosols they take up some
water until it is diluted enough that it
can initiate freezing or you can have
again immersion freezing but normally
here it's within some kind of solutions
or some sort of fade or so or you could
have directly vapor depositing on that
so it's a huge zoo that you see there
seven different possible pathways that
you can think of then the next question
is what particles what particles in the
atmosphere do we have that are good at
ice formation so this is actually work
from cubana whose or who was like
swapping places with where to work with
tudors so cool and i did a PhD with me
and moved to Norway and at the same time
through the switched and went from
nowhere to Switzerland so they know each
other pretty well so here what she then
she classified then all the difference
that is that you have on ice nucleation
and so this looks even much more of a
zoo than the figure I showed you from
the relat relat forcing that true to put
together what do you what do you see
when you look here the thing that you
see is that there's a large
area that's red and that's to guide you
that this is where you find dust mineral
does acting as a nice nucleus and I
think this is the thing that we agree
upon as a community that dust is
important it nucleates I said rather
warm temperatures up to around minus 10
these are all laboratory data when you
look here there's a little bit of a size
dependence in there so here the dust if
it's a star it's larger than 1 micron
and all those crosses are smaller than a
micron so the large particles start to
nucleate eyes first there's a few that
are unphysical because you cannot
sustain relative humidities over water
saturation that's not possible that is
measurement artifacts that also shows
you that we can't measure that too well
and then there is something that looks
promising in order to form eyes at the
warmest temperatures and there's a
so-called bio eros road so bacteria
fungi spores pollen so whatever the only
problem is that is not yet clear if they
play an important role in the atmosphere
because they are large and the question
is do they really get there where the
ice clouds are or not it doesn't seem to
be that they are numerous enough to
really have a big impact and then the
question is we have what what is really
numerous in the atmosphere would be sued
or organics but there for one are
smaller and when you look at this here
they don't really for mice at the
warmest temperatures maybe they are
important for servers but if they are
important for mixed phase cloud doesn't
look like that because they they only
appear close to the line where you have
water saturation already and then they
probably are not so helpful if they have
to compete with dust or bi or particles
but we don't know the jury is still out
there but when i said when i started
climbing modeling i was interested in
looking
the aerosol effect also on ice and so I
said okay I think we need to do some
measurements and that's how i got into
doing some measurements what we have
done at eth is that we have developed
instruments for all those different
modes of ice nucleation that I showed
you homogeneous deposition condensation
immersion contact so we build different
apparatuses for that and can study that
and so to show you some proof of concept
that we that we actually know what we
are doing if we look here at immersion
freezing data we have here silver iodide
which has been known from all cloud
seeding studies that this is good
because it has a crystal match that is
similar twice but you don't find it in
the atmosphere and here is Sampson this
this study aims at looking at biological
particles so we succeeded to have some
bird but it's washing water so what they
found and that's quite interesting is
that if you take biological particles
and wash them and take that water um
yeah and and and study the freezing of
that water after you have washed the
pollen it starts the nucleate ice so
it's not the whole pollen that you need
but there's some protein you know what
so ever that gets washed off the surface
and initiates freezing and yeah and so
we can we we agree that this this is if
more efficient than mineral dust so
kaolin ID is the mineral dust then you
see that here but there's for instance
the pine pine trees they don't do
anything pine washing water doesn't do
anything so there's nothing on the
needles that this is homogeneous
freezing down here so there is nothing
um yeah so so it works what we what we
also try to look at is the size
dependence on freezing i mentioned
before in colinas big figure that the
larger the particle the better they are
but one of the questions we will want to
if their minimum size do the particles
have to be of any minimum size to
nucleate ice and so the way you would
define it is if there is sufficient
freezing before here they hit this gray
bar which is so more genius freezing and
so this is mineral dust this is called
Arizona test dust and you see the most
the largest party goods they initiate
freezing at the warmest temperatures and
then the frozen fraction is of one where
all the particles are frozen is reached
at the warmest temperatures and
thereafter it's not so not so efficient
when we concluded from that it's around
100 nanometers because this is also
textbook knowledge you need around point
1 micrometer particles but it's not
really true that you need that because
we also did silver iodide for some other
reasons and if you look at silver iodide
particle you can freeze or much smaller
particles then you can with both with
mineral dust and the rationale here is
that it's because the silver iodide it
has such a similar structure to ice that
the lattice match is so good that also
smaller particles can actually cause ice
formation but what and what you notice
here is that there doesn't seem to be
much of a size dependence between 40
nanometer and larger which would make
sense if I said the lattice match is so
good so it freezes the nucleate size
regardless but something changes when
you come to being smaller than 40
nanometers and that has to do with that
silver iodide candy your survivor can
dissolve in water so what we calculated
is how long it takes before the silver
iodide particles so this here is our
check chembur that we have we have
around four seconds residence time in
the chamber and if you look at the it's
the same color code as before so these
are the 40
nanometer party goods those are the
largest and this is the 30-millimeter
and this year's the 20 nanometer
particle when you see that all the
larger ones survive but the 20 nanometer
dissolves and dissolves rather quickly
really quickly whereas the 30 nanometer
takes quite a while to dissolve and this
is what you see reflected here if they
if they are so large that they cannot
dissolve because the solution would be
way too saturated and the dissolution is
not that fast you see that they are very
efficient even if they are within a drop
but if they are able to dissolve and the
solution is still not saturated so they
dissolve completely you're left with
just emerging is freezing so what this
is nice is that that adds or something
about the physical process going on this
is not because it's atmospherically
relevant there's not a lot of silver
iodide out there okay what that's me so
the other thing that that is really
complicated so and the fears like
somebody in the audience has a good idea
what's going on yeah it's like the
question is it was often hypothesized or
they actually let's put it that way the
way I drew or Coogan I drew the
schematic here is suggest that contact
freezing is more efficient and more
efficient meaning that it starts at
warmer temperatures than the immersion
and so the question is why should that
be if you have a collision between a
nice nucleus and a droplet is that
really efficient or not it may release
some energy maybe it's the difference in
the surface because you have three
different interfaces you have air you
have the liquid you have the eyes but
it's not there's not too many studies
that are able to compare the two and so
we attempt to do that and we are
actually not here
actually not so sure that we have really
meaningful results by now what we tried
here again this is a mineral dust we try
to compare it with contact freezing with
the immersion and it looks like we may
see some warmer temperature ready where
the dust activates if it comes into
contact but there's a lot of noise in
our data and it also yeah that there's a
lot of noise and it's not consistent
it's maybe until a certain frozen
fraction and then they are
indistinguishable it doesn't really do
matter it doesn't depend too much on the
sides that seems if anything maybe here
is contact is more efficient then we
thought okay maybe we understand that
maybe our collision chamber isn't long
enough that enough collisions take place
and so we are limited by the average
number of collisions and that's why we
don't get to any higher frozen fraction
and so we made a longer chamber and now
we have some and that's where actually
why we did all the silver iodide
simulations because we had to figure out
if we can really find frozen fractions
all the way up to one can we really
freeze all the particles and silver
iodide is nice in that way because
silver iodide particles we can create a
really large concentration of with
mineral dust account they are too large
we don't get high number concentration
and so here we see something that yes we
get maybe not one but we get maybe up to
eighty percent if we have large enough
concentrations but if you now look at
this figure more closely silver iodide
before was shown to be one of the best
most ice nuclei initiating freezing at
the warmest temperatures and that's why
it was used early on in cloud seeding
studies and this year is rather cold
this year is already at mine is fifteen
or something like that that's not the
minus 42
minus five that we know from literature
and so we took those data and this is
now for a smaller concentration and
compared with our immersion freezing and
we seem we see we get it we get an
immersion freezing at least it's at a
decent temperatures of minus ten it's
even not the same as what we have with
other studies have seen but not with
contact so we just don't know what's
going on there either it doesn't want to
act as a contact nucleus or we have
problems with our chain my design we
just don't know but that was there those
really hard to explain what should be
going on there's really hard the only
thing that that I know for sure is that
it works because that was the what the
previous figures showed we are able to
to find out information so we don't know
yeah a little bit we don't really know
so then I can show you something that I
do know when but I do understand is that
when we look at the when we look at
observations so we also i started off is
showing you pretty pretty picture from
young fire and this now we go that we
have been going there since around five
or six years and have regularly take
measurements of ice nuclei concentration
there and because it's a 3,500 meters
and if you go there in winter you and
the free troposphere if you go there in
summer if you go in june then you can
have then you have much higher
concentrations and sde means that we
kept to Sahara dust events and if you go
during and said have a dusty once you
find that you have two orders of
magnitude higher ice nuclei
concentration and that makes sense so
then there's a lot of Sahara dust that
you see and we know dust as a good eyes
nucleus that all makes sense and that
you have higher concentrations and
summer than in winter could be some
evidence of biological particles because
in some are you do get the boundary
layer air being a hug coming up and then
you would have trees there you would
have the really biological particles we
don't know yet what they are but we are
planning to going back to
in the summer to understand what's going
on and there seemed to be quite a year
bit of year-to-year variability so the
background ice nucleation in the ice
nucleation concentration ice nuclei
concentration in the atmosphere is
rather variable and can be rather low so
that's what to conclude from here and
now also now this comes back to go spec
to these studies that you are doing here
with a supercooled liquid what we also
have is an holographic device that can
make pictures of ice crystals and water
droplets and from that so you see it
here it's here in the box and here you
see young for your if it's in the clouds
because you don't see anything it could
be everywhere about its own you employer
and and originally what we want to
figure out is how what is the
microstructure how exactly does the
microstructure look like do we have
pockets of crystals and other pockets of
water or is that homogeneously mixed and
of course I mean if you have everywhere
cloud droplet next to an crystal then
this Bergeron process would be very
efficient right that the ice crystals
grow at the expense of the water droplet
we don't know that yet what we do know
and this is where some fun questions of
fun science comes in if you look at the
supercooled liquid water fraction from
observations that's what wood has been
doing from satellite data here though
these are observations from Canada
inside stratiform supercooled clouds
different temperatures you seem to find
much more of a u-shape in that its most
of the time either completely water or
completely ice and Alexei Kovalev who
gave me those data has reanalyzed his
data and this is now for all of them
together it's really much more of a
u-shape so this is in clear contrast to
the Calliope p data from you and
actually i should tell you actually by
the way that somebody told me that they
have been reanalyzed and they also look
more usually
it when we need to talk about any of and
when we looked in union foyer we found
the same almost the same as what Alexei
Kovalev has from aircraft data in Canada
here but notice that it says here south
wind and if we come if the wind comes
from the north then we find much higher
fraction of supercooled liquid and now
the Arak raphy at you for you is kind of
like this so if it's from North it's
much deeper you have much higher up draw
velocities so what we hypothesize of
what we think happens is that here
because you have much higher updraft
velocities you exceed saturation with
respect to water all the time so you
form new cloud droplets but that would
be that there is quite a bit of dynamics
that are important for that and it's not
just a micro physical thing that's going
on but that the updraft velocity seems
to be of major importance there okay and
with that actually switched back a
little bit more to global so this is
what you know this is your paper this is
hear the Calliope data and of the super
good fraction and that if it's true but
I heard as I said that they have been
reanalyzed and may not show this huge
dependence anymore this would agree much
better to our the data from young foyer
for the North Slope this would fit to
that much lighter at the other point I
were to take away from here and is that
you see no none of the climate model
seems to get this temperature dependence
right they either have too much
supercooled liquid or too little and
there is probably an implication for
that on the total aerosol forcing
because if you look at this the
variation you have here is more than
what per meter square and they could
very well be related to how much
supercooled liquid they have one or it
could be related to many other things
but there could be something to do with
that um
one last point I said before the worst
is when I showed you the the ipcc
diagram of the arrows are forcing I said
that there were models in there that
were used to calculate the temperature
evolution from pre-industrial to present
what we did and it was a paper that we
have in preparation is to look at the
different climate models who
participated and group them into those
that are too warm or hot GCMs and that
refers to a reference period he ascended
between 1462 14 c 14 1942 1962 the right
ones in green and the cold ones in blue
and it looks like and there's a that
these hot ones are actually some that
don't take indirect Arizona effects into
account just by when you look at the
different at the model description we
could also show that that they really
have too little too little of an aerosol
forcing by comparing here their total
forcing and the total forcing is more or
less the sum of greenhouse gases and
aerosols so if the arrows are forcing is
is large then the total forcing is small
because the co2 is more or less is
comparable at least and so you see here
those warm GCMs they have a rather high
total forcing so that means they have a
rather small errors or forcing what's
shown here on the x-axis is what's
called climate resistance that's their
climate feedback parameter how you
translate the forcing into temperature
and the ocean heat uptake and it's also
true that those hot models don't put the
heat efficiently enough into the ocean
and if you put both of that together you
can conclude that the total errors or
forcing is at least point to watch per
meter square to week in them or maybe
even
for depends on the heap uptake or not
but there seemed to be some suggestion
that maybe actually the overall errors
are forcing from those seem of five
model should be more negative than it
actually is and there is actually other
studies who who agree with that okay and
then one very last point is the question
of how complicated should we actually
look at aerosol effects and climate
models what happened at least there has
been a tendency for all the models to
become more and more complex with time
and now include secondary organics and
nitrate and whatever else you can think
of and you do need it for depending on
what you want to study but the question
is do you also need that for getting
getting realistic errors or four things
or not so how much offer details of the
errors of physics do you actually need
and that's where we have done some
preliminary studies on that and i'm just
showing who you want results one outcome
of that is where we compare the forcing
estimates from say focus in the middle
here say the forcing estimates from
where we have online aerosols so we have
our different eras of species and the
different size classes and everything
online or when we from that construct
three-dimensional means of the aerosol
keep the dependence of supersaturation
that you need for our little activation
and then feed that back in and you see
that the overall the net forcing so this
on the right here is the net forcing is
pretty much comparable maybe there's
some small difference but the difference
is much smaller than if you go to a
different version of our model and
here's yet another version of the model
so what we seem to find that the details
of how we
read error source here again you can
also compare again red and blue here
they seem to be smaller than if we
change model versions from 11 version to
the next what is a little scary at the
moment is to do that that we don't
really know why on Anna Sun we have this
large long wave effect here that's
popping up all we know is that we fix
some bugs on the cloud microphysics so
that shouldn't really make such big of a
difference but but what it says and the
other difference that you also see in
here how does it depend on how you do
the simulation not means that you have
one year where you force the model
towards the observed observations from V
analysis or this is how you have the
model running in free mode what you do
if you go into future predictions or so
and again they seem to be those seem to
be rather comparable or at least more
comparable than if you switch modern
versions so there seemed to be something
in our model version switch that we need
to understand what's going on there okay
and so with that let me summarize what
I've shown you it's still after the 5th
IPCC assessment report it's still the
same that the total uncertainty due to
errors or radiation allows the cloud
interaction is the largest uncertainty
that we have in the anthropogenic
forcing there's lots of uncertainties
remaining in the details of ice
nucleation we do know that ice nuclei we
require a minimum size but that's not a
unique size but that depends on the
species so it's much larger from mineral
dust than it is for instance for server
you right and near the GCMs that
simulate a higher temperature than
observed in the 20th century we can have
shown that they there aerosol forcing is
too small so they should be that should
be more negative and then maybe there is
a point that we depending on what what
we are trying to study not everything
requires the details of all the
different errors or processes
it depends you need that a lot when you
are if you want to understand feedback
say between the biosphere and the
atmosphere then of course you need VOCs
and SOA and all that but if it's just
for forcing estimates maybe you just
don't need it maybe you can just get
away with monthly means but those
results are rather preliminary is what I
would say and with that I'd like to
thank you for your attention